- I can cut women's hair.
So like that's a good thing.
- You can?
- But I did,
I used to do just bangs
and things once in a while,
you know fringes and every once in a while
when they were younger,
you know tidy it up a little bit,
whatever I did.
You know make every once
in a while cut their bangs,
and they got a kick out of it.
When I tried to do my son,
it was, it was really a disaster
because I'm not a good,
he had some,
we would watch, you know
we watch TV in the morning,
like Sesame Street or this
or that or the other thing,
and I can't remember exactly
what we were watching,
but there was a, it was a some years ago,
he's like in his 30s now,
but there was a boy band or something
or something was going on,
there was a guy who had
a haircut that he liked,
and I said oh yeah I
probably could do that,
and I can't remember,
he must have been about seven years old.
- Oh my God, did you mess it up?
- And I messed it up so bad,
it was like you know just like then,
and the reaction was
crazy 'cause he wouldn't
get his haircut then
and you know he looked,
just wouldn't let anybody cut his hair.
- Oh you scarred him.
- What subsequently happened
was that I created this like
because of this you know,
doing this not very good job,
I wound up with a
nine year old, right,
who nine year Jake,
who's hair was like he was--
- Yeah a total surfer dude.
- a hippie.
He was like, it was
definitely like you know,
- Fabio.
- Like yeah, it was just like,
just totally off the
charts, wouldn't get it cut
and it was fun,
it was kind of like and the
girls got a kick out of it
because a lot
- You were good at theirs.
- he was a really good looking kid,
and every once in a while
they would go you know,
somebody would invariably say,
"Oh, you got three great
daughters" you know what I mean.
And they would get a kick out of it,
Jake would go, you know.
His call.
- He leaned in that's a lot of,
that's some comedy there
just in the making,
he leaned in.
So I mean,
I actually heard that it was
you went to beauty school
before you were an actor.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Is it was it your sister,
she owned a salon or something?
- My sister Angie was a,
she was 16 years older than,
she was the oldest in the family.
- Wow.
- I have two sisters,
two older sisters.
- That's quite a bit older, yeah.
- Yeah and when I graduated
she had a beauty parlor,
so she said "Why don't
you come to work for me"
and I was like 18 I think,
she said she'd send me to school to do it
and I said I don't know if I like can I?
Is this something that's
in my wheelhouse, you know?
- Yeah.
- Can I do this?
So we spent all summer, she
got me ready to go to school,
and she paid my way.
- Wow.
- And I got through it
and I got my license
and I and I and I worked in her salon
and then she abused me for
like three or four years.